[Musik]
und jetzt das heute schon mal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers in
allen einen guten Sonntagabend Italien
schlägt Alarm und es ist eine Mischung
aus tatsächlicher Notlage und
politischem Signal die rechtsgerichtete
Regierung in Rom steht gleich doppelt
unter Druck einmal weil am Dienstag
dieser Woche so viele Migranten auf der
Insel Lampedusa ankamen wie nie zuvor an
einem Tag zum anderen weil sie im
Wahlkampf einen härteren Kurs in der
Flüchtlingspolitik angekündigt hatte die
Zahlen der aus Nordafrika kommenden
Menschen aber immer weiter steigen heute
nimmt Regierungschefin Georgia Meloni
die Europäer mit in Haftung und zwar
ganz bildlich gesprochen sie nimmt die
kommissionspräsidentin mit nach
Lampedusa mit vor Ort und stellt die
Frage was hat die EU zu bieten außer
mehr oder weniger hilflosen Appellen an
die europäische Solidarität ultra damit
mehr
binnen drei Tagen sind mehr als 8000
Menschen mit Booten nach Lampedusa
geflohen sie haben ihr Leben riskiert um
nach Europa zu kommen nichts sagen sie
wird sie aufhalten
wir 48 Menschen waren in dem Boot es
hatte nur einen kleinen Motor und war
nicht groß vielleicht acht Meter
heute ist die
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
da Italiens offizielle haben den Ort ein
wenig aufgeräumt obwohl chaotische
Bilder zu verhindern von der Leyens
Besuch ist der Beleg das Europas
Migrationspolitik wieder einmal
scheitert Italien fühlt sich allein
gelassen
ich möchte noch einmal klarstellen es
geht hier nicht um eine
solidaritätskiste Europas sondern europa
muss Verantwortung übernehmen weil dies
nicht nur Italiens Grenze ist sondern
auch Europas
Sicherheitskräfte überwachen den Besuch
im aufnahme-lager die
eu-kommissionspräsidentin in schwieriger
Mission sie muss Mut machen weiß aber
dass viele EU-Länder mit den
Flüchtlingen nichts zu tun haben wollen
ein solidaritätsappell nicht zum ersten
Mal
wir bitten eindringlich alle EU-Staaten
freiwillig Flüchtlinge aus Italien
aufzunehmen
doch die befüllten auffanglage beweisen
dass die freiwillige Aufnahme in der EU
nicht funktioniert seit Jahren streiten
sie sich in Brüssel darüber auch jetzt
wird über ein neues eu-asylrecht
verhandelt aber Länder wie Polen und
Ungarn verweigern sich komplett es gibt
keine europäische Solidarität
die einwohner-
wir haben eine Botschaft an Europa
Lampedusa kann die Zustände nicht länger
aushalten
von der Leyen muss Hilfe anbieten sie
spricht vom Kampf gegen die Schlepper
und vom schnelleren abschieben dafür
braucht sie die Unterstützung von
Ländern wie Tunesien sehr viele
Flüchtlinge machen sich von dort auf den
Weg nach Europa deshalb reiste von der
Leyen im Juli nach Tunesien und
versprach dem Präsidenten viele hundert
Millionen Euro wenn er Migranten daran
hindert nach Europa zu fliehen aber
bisher funktioniert das Geschäft nicht
wir werden mit Tunesien daran arbeiten
dass der Vertrag umgesetzt wird
wir werden deshalb die zugesagten
Projekte und die Zahlungen beschleunigen
von der Leyen verlässt die Insel und
wird wohl bald wieder mit Tunesien oder
anderen Ländern in Afrika sprechen damit
sie die Migranten festhalten dafür ist
Europa bereit viel Geld zu zahlen
der Migrationsforscher Gerald Knaus ist
bei uns genannter Knaus guten Abend sie
gelten als Vordenker des
eu-türkeiabkommens mit dem die Zahl der
Migranten über die EG ist reduziert
werden sollte wenn Sie jetzt den
Auftritt heute von Ursula von der Leyen
auf einer anderen Route nämlich in
Lampedusa sehen was ist ja Eindruck hat
die EU einen Plan
naja die uh dann einen Plan einen zehn
Punkteplan das Problem ist wenn ich alle
zehn Punkte Pläne der letzten zehn Jahre
zusammennehme und die Aktionspläne und
Strategiepapiere und
Rückführungsabkommen die alle nicht
funktioniert haben wahrscheinlich
könnten sie ihr ganzes Studio damit
tapezieren und das Ergebnis ist
einsichtig und offensichtlich wir haben
in diesem Jahr viel mehr Menschen die
ihre gut aus Afrika nach Italien kommen
als in den letzten Jahren vielleicht
überhaupt ein Rekord wir haben tausende
Tote auch wieder in diesem Jahr wir
haben so wenig Rückführungen wie vor
oder weniger Rückführungen als vor fünf
Jahren nach Afrika das dublin-system ist
zusammengebrochen also in jeder Hinsicht
und mit dem zynischen Deal den Libyen
und Indonesien werden auch noch
Menschenrechte verletzt in jeder
Hinsicht ist der Europäische Union hier
bis jetzt gescheitert
werden wir gleich darüber was man tun
müsste bleiben auch Moment bei dem ist
Zustand wir haben da heute ein Appell
gehört von Ursula von der Leyen wieder
mal wie sie sagen ein Appell an andere
EU-Staaten freiwillig Migranten aus
Italien aufzunehmen Deutschland
interessanterweise hat exakt das gerade
gestoppt die bundesinnenministerin
verspricht aber auch heute wieder
Solidarität wie passt denn das zusammen
die ganze Debatte um Solidarität in der
Europäischen Union ist sehr verwirrend
ich gebe Ihnen nur eine Zahl zwei Zahlen
im letzten Jahr hat Italien ungefähr
86.000 Asylanträge Österreich hatte
110.000 also mehr Italien im letzten
Jahr Italien ungefähr 26.000 Menschen
Schutz gewährt Deutschland hat fünfmal
mehr Menschen Schutz gewährt als Italien
wenn man also von einer gerechten
Verteilung reden würde in Europa dann
müsste man Menschen aus Österreich und
Deutschland nach Italien schicken und
nicht umgekehrt dass Italien damit
überfordert ist auf einer winzigen Insel
ein paar tausend Leute unterzubringen
ist kein Zeichen dafür dass Italien
besonders viele Asylsuchenden oder
Flüchtlinge im Land hat Polen sie haben
über die Solidarität gesprochen hat
zehnmal mehr Ukrainerinnen aufgenommen
als Italien also die Debatte um
Solidarität muss ernsthaft geführt
werden mit richtigen Zahlen und nicht
mehr mit Schlagworten da ist halt
wahnsinnig viel Politik mit dabei
Georgia Meloni die italienische Minister
Präsidentin macht Riesenwirbel aktuell
und sie sagt sie will jetzt notfalls
auch ihre eigene Marine einsetzen und
zwar sofort um Menschen in Nordafrika
vom ablegen abzuhalten was würde das
denn bedeuten
das ist leider nicht erstaunlich sie hat
immerhin eine Koalition auch mit der
Partei von Matthäus Salvini der war auch
schon mal Innenminister der
Innenminister jetzt in Italien ist von
der Lega und die hat schon einmal 2009
mit der italienischen Marine Bote
gestoppt und damals nach Libyen
zurückgebracht
andere Länder machen das weltweit die
USA in der Karibik Australien im
Indischen Ozean aber damals hat der
europäische Gericht so von der
Europäische Menschenrechtsgerichtshof
dies als menschenrechtswidrig und
eu-rechtswidrig verurteilt also wenn
Italien jetzt darüber nachdenkt mit dem
Militär wurde zurückzustoßen und nach
Tunesien wird das nicht gehen die nehmen
sie nicht also vielleicht höchstens nach
Libyen dann wäre das ein Angriff auf das
Fundament der europäischen
Rechtsstaatlichkeit allerdings
matthäuser wollte die EU und die
Menschenrechtskonvention immer zum
Einsturz bringen so gesehen würde das
passen aber für Europa den
Flüchtlingsschutz und die
Rechtsstaatlichkeit wäre das der
schwerste Tag überhaupt
schon gesagt sie waren Vordenker für
dieses Abkommen zwischen der EU und der
Türkei was aktuell auch nicht mehr so
wahnsinnig gut funktioniert jetzt soll
es ja ein weiteres Abkommen mit Tunesien
geben aktuell gibt's eine
Absichtserklärung trotzdem haben wir
gerade gesehen kommen gerade aus
Tunesien so viele Flüchtlinge wie nie
zuvor an einem Tag heißt das die
tunesische Regierung macht trotzdem
geldversprechens eigentlich gar nichts
sie haben den das richtige Wort genannt
versprechen wir haben auch mit der
Türkei sechs Monate verhandelt die
Europäische Union ohne jeden Erfolg
zwischen September 2015 und März 2016
und diese sechs Monate haben sich
dadurch ausgezeichnet dass nur
Versprechen gemacht wurden das ist
keinen klaren präzisen Plan gab was man
von der Türkei erwartet was man hier
verspricht im März 2016 hat die Türkei
dann ein kurzes Papier vorgelegt sehr
präzise und dieses Papier hat dann die
Situation gewendet und die Zahl der
kommenden ist auf 3% gefallen die
Einigung mit Tunesien ist Waage lang
voller versprechen unkonkret und es ist
überhaupt nicht klar was Tunesien
eigentlich machen sollte und es ist auch
nicht klar was die EU Tunesien wirklich
verspricht also als migrationsabkommen
ist das nicht tauglich und ist das jetzt
noch ein Grund dafür warum Tunesien
aktuell sagt seht her wir können auch
anders und ihr seht was passiert
das Paradoxe ist ja aufgrund oder
während dieser Verhandlungen mit
Tunesien hat sich die Menschenrechtslage
in Tunesien drastisch verschärft für
Menschen aus subsara Afrika ist es im
Cerne sich an die Bilder die Menschen
die in die Wüste gebracht wurden an die
libysche Grenze ohne Wasser im Sommer
die Lager hat sich verschärft und da ist
ein Anreiz entstanden für noch mehr
Menschen sich in die Boote zu setzen
also paradoxerweise ist das Schlechte
undurchdachte Abkommen mit Tunesien auch
ein Grund dafür dass jetzt mehr Menschen
kommen als davor ganz kurz noch ein Haus
die Bundesregierung hat ja was viele
nicht wissen ein sonderbevollmächtigten
für migrationsabkommen Joachim stammt
von der FDP warum hört man von dem so
wenig bis gar nichts
also das Problem in dieser Situation ist
das muss eine Chefsache sein denn und
ich hoffe dass der deutsche
Bundeskanzler und und auch der
französische Präsident in New York
nächste Woche hier auch Gespräche führen
denn es geht hier wirklich um das
Fundament auf dem Europa steht und
tausende Menschenleben der Beauftragte
Joachim Stamm ist im Innenministerium
angesiedelt aber wir brauchen hier die
Kooperation aller Ministerien
Außenministerium Sozialministerium
Kanzleramt um Angebote zu machen
anstarten in Afrika sichere Drittstaaten
dass Sie sicher sein wollen dran sieht
starten Herkunftsländer um Menschen
zurückzunehmen äh so viel ich weiß hat
sich der migrationsbeauftragte vor allem
derzeit um ein Abkommen mit Georgien und
Moldau gekümmert das ist für Deutschland
sehr wichtig das hätte man auch schon
früher schließen sollen aber der Streit
in der Koalition hat das bis jetzt sehr
schwierig gemacht also ich glaube das
ist auch eine Krise der Koalition es ist
sicher eine Krise der Europäischen Union
und Ernsthaftigkeit mit
Rechtsextremisten Parteien überall in
Europa die wachsen und die natürlich von
diesen Bildern profitieren mit diesem
Kontrollverlust die Ernsthaftigkeit sehe
ich immer noch nicht bei den Regierungen
und auch in Deutschland diese Probleme
jetzt nicht nur mit Schlagworten sondern
mit umsetzbaren Plänen zu konfrontieren
der Appell des migrationsforschers an
alle eigentlich muss man sagen
herzlichen Dank ich danke Ihnen
und damit heute Abend im heute schon
unser nächstes Thema eine Brandmauer
auch Brandwand oder Feuermauer genannt
soll durch ihre Beschaffenheit das
Übergreifen von Feuer und Rauch von
einem Gebäude auf ein anderes verhindern
sie muss deshalb besonders beständig
standsicher und dick sein Zweifel an
diesen Eigenschaften darf es nicht geben
die politische Brandmauer die der
CDU-Chef gegenüber der AFD hochgezogen
hat ist aktuell allerdings heftig in der
Diskussion nachdem die CDU in Thüringen
ein Gesetz ausgerechnet mit dem AFD
Landesverband durchs Parlament gebracht
hat der aus Verfassungsschutz Sicht
erwiesen rechtsextrem ist
gibt es die Mauer noch ist sie nur noch
ein neuerchen oder steht da maximal ein
Feuerlöscher in der Ecke da wird Gebhard
war unterwegs im Osten Deutschlands und
hat immer wieder die Frage gehört welche
Brandmauer
neulich im Bundestag Friedrich Merz
posiert für Gruppenfotos da ist sie
gerade eine Sommerpause alt seine Ansage
zur AFD diese Partei ist
ausländerfeindlich diese Partei ist an
diese mytisch wir haben mit diesen
Leuten nichts zu tun hinter seinem
Rücken auf der anderen Seite der Scheibe
sitzt in diesem Moment Mario makowiak
Mitglied einer
CDU-Gemeinderatsfraktion und hier als
Teil einer sächsischen Reisegruppe auf
Einladung von ausgerechnet afd-chef Tino
propala
hat gesagt mit diesen Leuten haben wir
nichts zu tun mit der AFD ist das auch
ihr Eindruck nein überhaupt nicht
überhaupt nicht wir reden völlig offen
wir arbeiten völlig offen zusammen wir
haben null Brandenburgern wir fahren
nach Krauschwitz nee Görlitz Heimat von
propala zur nächsten Sitzung der
Gemeinderäte wie reagieren die
cdu-kollegen auf den Besuch beim
afd-chef
das ist in Ordnung warum hat er mich ja
nicht mehr eingeladen
statt Brandmauer gibt es hier das
gemeinsame Bier mit dem afd-kollegen wir
sehen uns auch in der Freizeit und
deswegen geht es ja wirklich nur um
Themen Sachebene weiter in den Kreis
Meißen Teile der CDU-Basis hier denken
bei Brandmauer eher an die Grünen
berufen sich dabei auf den Parteichef
der leider sich selbst hochgehängt indem
er gesagt hat keine Zusammenarbeit mit
den Grünen Grünen sind kein
Koalitionspartner für die CDU sie
fordern eine Minderheitsregierung in
Sachsen mit wechselnden Mehrheiten je
nach Thema dann vielleicht auch mal mit
der AFD
eins ist von vornherein ausgeschlossen
das ist irgendetwas mit der AFD gibt
solange ich hier noch was zu sagen habe
unterwegs sind Thüringen hier ist die
Lage für die CDU noch ernster nach dem
ersten Landrat für die AFD könnte in
Nordhausen bald ein AFD
Oberbürgermeister Folgen im ersten
Wahlgang 42 Prozent der viert platzierte
CDU-Kandidat 11 beerdigungsstimmung das
Schlimme ist dass die Leute die
vielleicht harmlos daherkommen für
solche Leute wie Birnen höcke das Feld
bereiten und das macht mir Angst für
Björn höcke vom Verfassungsschutz als
Rechtsextremist eingestuft war das eine
gute Woche in Thüringer Landtag brachte
am Donnerstag die CDU einen Antrag zum
Haushalt durch mit den Stimmen seiner
afd-fraktion bundespolitischer
Sprengstoff es geht um Grundsätzliches
es darf auch nie auf die Stimmen der AFD
ankommen wenn es um die Mehrheit geht es
war ein Antrag der CDU-Fraktion so und
der hat eine Mehrheit bekommen aber wir
richten uns dann nach wer zustimmt
sondern wir richten uns danach was wir
in der Sache für richtig halten ich
bilde keine Mehrheiten mit Extremisten
und wenn ich darauf angewiesen bin dann
weiß ich in dem Augenblick ich kann
meine Hand nicht dafür heben zu Besuch
in Greiz Thüringen bei der CDU Landrätin
womöglich nach der Landtagswahl in einem
Jahr dann im Landtag was sagt sie zum
formalen Beschluss der Bundespartei
keine Zusammenarbeit mit der AFD dieser
Beschluss ist überflüssig wieder Schmutz
zu Ostern und Sie werden keine klare
Definition für so etwas finden das
Konrad adenauer-haus sollte sich
tunlichst zurückhalten wie die ehemalige
sed-parteileitung in Berlin die Doktrin
vorzugeben was man denken und zu fühlen
und zu tun und zu lassen hat zurück in
Berlin die beschworene Brandmauer wird
eher wie der durchlässige Bauzaun neben
der Partei zentrale die
cdu-orientierungslos schon bei der Frage
was keine Zusammenarbeit mit der AFD
eigentlich meint
ja sie merken schon das Thema ist nicht
vorbei frontal beschäftigt sich
eingehend damit am Dienstag 21 Uhr wie
gewohnt hier im ZDF und wir bleiben auch
noch beim Thema und einem Appell dazu an
die Politik von einem ehemaligen
Staatsoberhaupt Hanna ja der ehemalige
bundespräsident Gauck hat Angesicht
s der bei Berlin direkt erklärte er eine
Begrenzung der Zuwanderung sei politisch
geboten Politik braucht Mehrheiten und
wenn in vier verschiedenen Ländern unter
diesem Migrationsdruck unter dieser
Zuwanderung in eine Maß wie 20 15 die
Bevölkerung den Eindruck hat die
Regierenden verstehen nicht dass wir das
Bedürfnis haben nach Überschaubarkeit
und Sicherheit dann wird es zu einem
weiteren rechtsdruck kommen
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat sich dafür
ausgesprochen die Tarifbindung in
Deutschland zu stärken es brauche mehr
Tarifverträge nicht weniger sagte er bei
der Eröffnung des wer die
Bundeskongresses in Berlin zudem
erklärte Scholz dass er trotz
schwieriger Zeiten keinen Grund sehe den
Sozialstaat zurückzufahren im Gegenteil
es sei ein gutes Zeichen dass sich die
sozialstaatlichen Sicherungen in
Deutschland verbessert hätten
mehrere Bundes- und Landespolitiker
haben die gewaltsamen Ausschreitungen
bei einer Eritrea Veranstaltung in
Stuttgart scharfer urteilt und klare
Konsequenzen gefordert gestern waren
mehrere hundert Gegner und Anhänger des
eritreischen Regimes am Rande eines
Treffens aufeinander losgegangen dabei
wurden auch 27 Polizisten verletzt
insgesamt 228 Personen wurden laut
Polizei zeitweise festgenommen ihnen
werde unter anderem schwerer
Landfriedensbruch vorgeworfen
[Musik]
Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg hat die
Bundesregierung dazu aufgerufen ihre
Verteidigungsausgaben deutlich zu
erhöhen er erwarte von Deutschland
mindestens das zwei Prozent Ziel zu
erreichen sagte er der Funke
Mediengruppe und fügte hinzu im Kalten
Krieg hätten die Militärausgaben
Deutschlands bei drei bis vier Prozent
gelegen dies müsse heute wieder
geschafft werden
klimaaktivistinnen und Aktivisten der
sogenannten letzten Generation haben das
Brandenburger Tor mit Farbe besprüht
alle sechs Säulen waren davon betroffen
bei der Aktion sein präparierte
Feuerlöscher genutzt worden erklärte die
klimaschutzgruppe die Polizei nahm 14
Personen fest gegen diese werde wegen
gemeinschaftlicher Sachbeschädigung
ermittelt
Corona glauben Sie mir das Wort würde
ich am liebsten nie wieder in den Mund
nehmen müssen die Pandemie ist vorbei
aber das Virus ist nicht weg und der
Herbst kommt die Zahlen steigen aktuell
leicht und eine Reihe von sonst sehr
vorsichtigen Experten ist eher
optimistisch für den Winter dennoch
fragen sich sicher manche nochmal impfen
lassen ab morgen soll in den Praxen ein
angepasster Impfstoff verfügbar sein wo
stehen wir also Zeit für ganz
unaufgeregte Fakten von Eva Schiller
wenn Ärztin Claudia Künstler C im
Pflegeheim nahe Stuttgart den neuen
corona-impfstoff anspricht dann schlägt
ihr eine Mischung aus mildem Interesse
und Corona Müdigkeit entgegen
Konrad waldhart ist 94 nochmal impfen
keinesfalls
abgearbeitet ist gut ja ihnen würde ich
jetzt nicht versuchen zu überzeugen weil
er das sehr überzeugend schon vertritt
dass er auf keinen Fall sich impfen
lassen möchte wenn es jetzt jemand wäre
der so ein bisschen zaudert und auch
Sorge hat dann würde ich auf jeden Fall
eigentlich eher zu der Impfung raten
empfohlen wird die Auffrischungsimpfung
für vorerkrankte und Menschen ab 60 das
Interesse hält sich in Grenzen Corona
hat seinen Schrecken verloren ja es
blocken aller Orten wieder Fälle auf wie
viele genau weiß keiner dass er KI fast
mittlerweile alle Erkältungsviren
zusammen nur etwa ein Fünftel sind
Corona-Viren und auch die neue Variante
piroler sorgt Virologen wenig
die ersten Daten die es aus dem Labor
gibt zu dieser neuen Variante sind dass
sie schon auch infektiöses infektiöser
ist als andere Varianten aber dass die
jetzt nicht so anders ist als die
Varianten die wir schon kennen da ist
dieses nie wieder pandemiegefühl bei
vielen die verlorene Zeit samt Lockdown
und ffp2-maske vergessen verdrängen das
ist zwar verständlich findet
medizinetikerin Alena Büchs aber auch
kurzsichtig uns ist das ja genommen
worden nach dieser furchtbaren Zeit der
Pandemie gemeinsam aufzuarbeiten und zu
heilen und das wäre so wichtig gewesen
gerade mit Blick auf die Jungen die ja
wirklich gelitten haben da gab es so
eine unerwiderte Solidarität zu haben
wir das genannt und ich würde mir
wirklich wünschen dass wir da stärker
hingucken die Jungen stärker ins Zentrum
Stellen an Deutschlands größter
Kinderklinik in Stuttgart macht sich
Kinder infektiologe Friedrich Reichert
um alles mögliche sorgen aber nicht um
Corona die kontaktbeschränkungen
damals führten dazu dass die kleinen
massenweise Infekte nachholen mussten
die Kinderkliniken am Anschlag jetzt
gelte es vorzubeugen glaub schon dass
wir bei Kindern ein bisschen zu viel auf
Corona und zu wenig auf die anderen
Probleme geschaut haben gleichzeitig hat
die Rückkehr der anderen Infekte ja dazu
geführt dass der Fokus jetzt auf die auf
den Kinderkliniken und auf der
Versorgung von kranken Kindern liegt und
ich würde mir wünschen dass man da auch
für die Zukunft ansetzt in den
Kinderkliniken stärkt und über die
Immunisierung nachdenkt gegen Grippe
impfen gegen den Atemwegsinfekt RSV
immunisieren das finden sie hier wichtig
ja es rollt wie jedes Jahr eine
infektwelle auf Deutschland zu aber
Corona wird nur noch ein Virus von
vielen sein
[Musik]
so sportliches jetzt der sonntagssport
mit Jana
bei den Tischtennis Team
Europameisterschaften in Malmö haben die
deutschen Männer Silber gewonnen im
Finale mussten sie sich nur Gastgeber
Schweden geschlagen geben mit eins zu
drei noch erfolgreicher waren die
deutschen Frauen das Trio shiona Shan
und Nina Mittel haben verteidigte den
EM-Titel im Finale gegen Rumänien mit
drei zu null
in der Fußball-Bundesliga gab es heute
zwei Begegnungen der erste fC Heidenheim
besiegte Werder Bremen mit vier zu zwei
und feierte zugleich noch einen Rekord
denn Trainer Frank Schmidt übernahm
Heidenheim auf den Tag genau vor 16
Jahren und ist nun der dienstälteste
Trainer im deutschen Profifußball
außerdem traf Darmstadt 98 auf Borussia
Mönchengladbach entstand drei zu drei
zum Tennis das deutsche Davis Cup Team
hat den Klassenerhalt beim
traditionsreichen Mannschaftswettbewerb
geschafft und bleibt damit in der
Weltgruppe der Topnationen beim
Relegationsspiel siegte die deutsche
Auswahl gegen Gastgeber
Bosnien-Herzegowina das Weltklasse
Doppel Kevin Krawitz und Tim Pütz sorgte
mit seinem Sieg heute für den dritten
Punkt und damit die vorzeitige
Entscheidung
die Pyramiden von Gizeh sind schon lange
UNESCO Weltkulturerbe die Inka Stadt
Machu Picchu auch das heißt sie stehen
unter dem besonderen Schutz der
Weltgemeinschaft so auch der Aachener
Dom zum Beispiel sie sind bzw werden
häufig gerade dadurch zu absoluten
Touristenmagneten seit heute hat die
Welt zwei neue Welterbestätten und zwar
die Ruinen der antiken Stadt Jericho in
den palästinensischen Autonomiegebieten
im Westjordanland die Menschen dort
sagen stolz wir leben in der
ältesten Stadt der Welt
stolz können Sie auch in Erfurt sein
Deutschland war dieses Jahr nur mit
einer einzigen Bewerbung im Rennen aber
die hat es geschafft und sie hat es
verdient Daniela Sonntag er darf das
Jubel auf den die Erfurter 15 Jahre lang
hingearbeitet haben heute nun die
Entscheidung in Riad die jüdischen
Städten in Erfurt sind Welterbe
in einer Liga mit mit den Pyramiden in
Ägypten mit mit mit mit der chinesischen
Mauer mit Machu Picchu das ist schon das
ist schon was besonderes Juden die in
letzter Zeit ja nach Thüringen gekommen
sind die spüren Erfurt hat jüdisches
Leben und nicht nur heute wieder sondern
immer schon gehabt
mitten in der Stadt mitten im Leben das
jüdische Erbe Erfurts eine der ältesten
Synagogen Europas Teile davon tausend
Jahre alt sie war Lagerhalle und
Tanzhaus und hat so die Jahrhunderte und
den Nazi Terror überstanden heute ist
die Museum zu sehen unter anderem der
Erfurter Schatz Gold Silber und das
Prunkstück der Hochzeitsring und das
hier eben eine Synagoge mit den ältesten
Teilen aus dem 11 jahrhundert heute noch
steht bis zur Dachkante aus
mittelalterlichen Substanz besteht heute
benutzbar ist dass es wirklich
außergewöhnlich erst ein Abriss von
Nachbarhäusern legte Ende der 90er das
alte jüdische Erbe wieder frei die Mieke
das jüdische rituelle Bad sogar erst
2007 gefunden das steinerne Haus wird
noch saniert all das ein Welterbe das
lange schlummerte während es in Erfurt
den einzigen Synagogen Neubau zu
DDR-Zeiten gab und bis heute eine
jüdische Gemeinde
Lutz Balzer ist seit Jahren beim
Bürgerradio aktiv versucht jüdisches
Leben zu erklären und am Leben zu halten
einerseits schockiert mich manchmal wie
wenig die Leute überhaupt wissen über
jüdisches Leben andererseits freut mich
wenn gerade junge Leute wenn ich mit
denen über das Thema in ins Gespräch
komme und deswegen gebe ich auch die
Hoffnung nicht auf dass da vielleicht
auch mal wieder mehr Interesse entsteht
das Welterbe für ihn eine Chance seine
Kultur wieder sichtbarer zu machen und
nach den schuhstätten von Speyer Worms
und Mainz ist Erfurt nun das zweite
jüdische Welt Erbe in Deutschland
und das ist auch etwas was in die
Zukunft weiß das bedeutet Zusammenhalt
das bedeutet sich unserer Geschichte
bewusst zu sein und das bedeutet auch
eine große vermittlungsaufgabe für die
Welterbestätten so soll auch ein
Infozentrum entstehen Erfurt hofft auf
Besucher aus aller Welt aber heute
erstmal feiern
zu Recht und jetzt wie traditionell am
Sonntag der Blick auf das was vor uns
liegt der heute journal Ausblick von
Kamera
[Musik]
vor dem Bonner Landgericht muss ich ab
Montag der frühere Chef der Warburg Bank
Christian olearius im cum-ex-skandal
verantworten olearius wird besonders
schwere Steuerhinterziehung in 14 Fällen
vorgeworfen brisant auch der Name des
früheren Hamburger Bürgermeisters und
heutigen Kanzlers taucht in der Anklage
auf
ab Dienstag werden in New York mehr als
140 Staats- und Regierungschefs zur
un-generaldebatte erwartet erstmals seit
Beginn des
ukraine-lensky persönlich anwesend sein
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz wird seine
Rede in der Nacht zum Mittwoch halten
am Mittwoch wird das britische
Königspaar Frankreich besuchen auf dem
Reiseplan von Charles dem dritten und
seiner Frau Camilla ein Staatsbank hält
auf Schloss Versailles eine Rede vor dem
französischen Parlament und eine Visite
in Bordeaux dort besucht das Paar ein
Bio-Weingut
am Samstag wird die CSU auf ihrem
Parteitag in München einen neuen
Vorstand wählen Parteichef Markus Söder
und die CSU wollen vor der Bayern Wahl
Geschlossenheit demonstrieren auch nach
den Querelen in der eiwanger-affäre um
ein antisemitisches Flugblatt
fehlt noch ein weiterer Ausblick und
zwar auf die Wetteraussichten morgen
gibt es im Westen und in der Mitte
Schauer und Gewitter im Osten bleibt es
bis zum Abend meist trocken die
Temperatur erreicht 22 Grad an der
Nordsee und 30 Grad im Spreewald der
Dienstag wird mit 17 bis 24 Grad
deutlich kühler und vor allem im
Nordwesten und im Südosten wechselhaft
ab Mittwoch wird es wieder wärmer und
größtenteils auch freundlich
sehr schön ich habe hier schon so ein
bisschen aufgeräumt denn wir zwei sagen
im Namen des gesamten Teams auch der
Kolleginnen und Kollegen hinter den
Kameras danke schön für Ihr Interesse
und ab morgen freuen sich hier Dunja
Hayali und Gundula Gause auf sie und die
nächsten Nachrichten gibt's
mit Christopher Wehrmann tschüss
[Musik]